tristes heures afin le maire de saint
pierre dans son caddie ce matin bonjour
séraphin bonjour vous avez entendu les
informations rodolphe désiré maire du
marin qui annonce qu'il ne se
représentera pas il a 81 ans il se
retire après 35 ans de mandature
rodolphe désiré himer du marais il ya
quelques semaines c'était pierre samot
qu'ils se retiraient des affaires de
dinosaures de la vie politique qui se
retire en commentaire séraphin je dirais
deux monuments de la vie politique
martiniquaise et que je salue
particulièrement moi je désire ligne de
mire j'essaie de m'en inspirer en
particulier de rodolphe désiré que
j'étais halak fait perdre en lanières et
il m'a interpellé en tant que maire de
saint-pierre me demandant de ne pas
avoir peur de mouiller et quand l'eau et
roches hôtes m'at-il dit il faut y aller
tout habillé et donc j'ai retenu un sens
et un visionnaire c'est quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse énormément à saint-pierre
parce qu'ils s'estiment pierrot tu as
donc nous avons un excellent contact et
il m'a invité à le rencontrer plus
souvent je pense qu'il ya beaucoup pas à
retenir de ce grand sage de la politique
quant à pierre samot moi j'admire aussi
son parcours
l'évolution du dam en terre on le lui
doit j'aime bien sa sagesse soit son
approche de la politique distancié pas
de violences beaucoup de charisme
ce sont des hommes qui inspire vous êtes
tenté par des mandatures à rallonge
plusieurs années à la mairie de
saint-pierre malheureusement ou
heureusement j'ai commencé beaucoup plus
tard que en politique je pense pas que
ce soit le temps qu'il soit le seul
paramètre
j'essaye de faire au mieux j'espère
j'espère pouvoir laisser une trace
peut-être pas aussi importante que mais
une petite trace aussi de ce que
j'aurais fait pour saint pierre tristan
rafah la ville d'art et d'histoire au
devant de l'actualité en fin de semaine
dernière après une ultime publication de
la chambre régionale des comptes
confirmant un déficit de près de 2
million et demi durant une confirmation
mais qui ne règle pas tout qu'entendez
vous faire de ce document si ce n'est
enfoncer davantage l'équipe précédente
dans son mode de gestion
ça n'est pas le seul objectif ordre je
voulais d'abord ça va sur vous
surprendre dur que vous avez en face de
vous n'est peut-être pas un maire
heureux mais un maire soulagé et amer
satisfait que et qui remercie le préfet
soulagé oui et la chambre gérald est
content d'avoir de bonnes m'avoir enfin
permis de faire la lumière officielle
sur la situation de la ville que j'ai
dénoncée depuis 2010 ça fait plus de
huit ans que j'ai signalé que c'est un
conseiller municipal d'opposition
mission et j'ai écrit à la chambre
régionale des comptes au préfet j'ai
même je suis moi même monté au niveau du
ministère de l'intérieur là mme
alliot-marie monsieur christian estrosi
ont été avertis que la ville était déjà
au delà des critères de la chambre
régionale des comptes et que rien n'a
été fait en arrivant à m'expliquer ce je
m'en foutisme de l'époque de la part des
autorités de contrôle jeu c'est pour ça
que moi je continue en disant que en
arrivant j'ai voulu faire une
photographie de la situation pour qu'on
ne dise pas après que je n'avais pas dit
et que c'était ma gestion qui en étaient
qui était la cause de cette situation
alors je ne sais pas pourquoi de terre
n'a pas réagi en tout cas je constate
que le sous-préfet de l'époque qui était
la schl à ces biens étaient déjà sur le
regard du réseau d' alerte et il m'a dit
lui même que la mairie de saint-pierre
n'avait pas de comptabilité c'était
comme un grand entonnoir dans lequel on
versait de l'argent et ça fuite partout
en bas donc tout le monde était
conscient de cela je ne sais pas
pourquoi matière à porter plainte
cette situation quand même que vous
dénonciez depuis 2010 a quand même d une
incidence sur le ventre des 3 yuki jotas
que les trois millions cinq de rom 3
millions d'euros de déficit
masqué sous forme de contentieux de plus
d'un million 2 2 millions de factures
dans les tiroirs qui n'avaient pas été
inscrits dans les comptes ne pénalise
pas ce que petit à petit on purge ce
retard j'en suis a déjà nous avons déjà
purgé un million cinq de ses factures en
instance ça freine notre notre activité
donc maintenant je remercie là encore
une fois le préfet qui m'accompagne déjà
et qui a entendu mon appel en disant
voilà peut-être que on aurait dû faire
le nécessaire
ça n'a pas été fait les contrôles n'ont
pas été effectués les l'action régionale
des comptes dit en 2018
côté bilan d'avant de mon prédécesseur
était faux donc je récupère cette
situation comme le demande pas de
sacrifier le quotidien des pires autun
pour faire de la gestion financière
c'est pour ça je gère c'est pour ça que
vous demandez et j'agis vous ce que vous
demandez à l'état bas puisqu'il n'est
pas fait le travail à l'époque
donnez moi de l'argent pour accomplir le
programme sur lequel je dis que la
changer leur accoutrement témoin n'est
pas volé j'ai eu deux magistrats de la
chambre des comptes avec qui j'ai fait
un excellent travail grâce aux
financiers que j'ai embauché depuis
février 2018 pour pallier aux carences
de la comptabilité de la mairie je leur
ai demandé déjà du temps donc j'ai
obtenu cinq ans pour parce que je leur
ai dit je vais pas arrêter les comptes
de la mairie
la gestion de la ville pour gérer les
comptes financiers
donc j'ai déjà le temps et j'ai dit
allez allez tu as maintenant ce que si
il veut que j'allais plus vite il faut
me donner une dotation de rééquilibrage
de ses ultimatums ça y ressemble ainsi à
nommer celui là d'où je suis je suis
très clair là-dessus les pires auteurs
n'ont pas à subir ce qui n'a pas été
fait pendant des années alors que j'ai
signalé à tout le monde la situation
maintenant je veux bien assumer je suis
maire je récupère l'actif et le passif
je vais y aller mais qu'on ne me demande
pas de faire le bon élève au détriment
des pilotes alors vous avez jusqu en
2000 fait la ville de saint-pierre a
jusqu à 2023 pour réduire le déficit
c'est possible on achète aussi mais
mettons nous dans une situation la plus
difficile pour vous à savoir que l'état
vous dis y'a pas moyen y a pas d'argent
on peux pas vous donner cette chance là
dessus vous avez remarqué que la chambre
général de conteuse a fait des
préconisations qui sont que l'on
décapsule explique par exemple de
maîtriser la masse salariale très
clairement tout en veillant à qualifier
dans l'encadrement parce que j'ai trouvé
une mairie quasiment sans encadrement
donc il s'agit pas d'arrêter les les
recrutements mais de mieux gérer les
choses assuré les évolutions de carrière
voilà à sur l'évolution continuelle
évolution de carrière parce qu'ils ont
reconnu que damas salariat qui a
augmenté et est dû au fait que des
carriers avait été bloqué pendant
plusieurs années et donc rechercher des
économies en termes de dépenses et ce
que nous avons déjà commencé par exemple
l'éclairage public va faire l'objet
d'une rénovation complète c'est une des
plus grosses factures de la mairie avec
l'aide de la semaine du ce même et d'edf
nous allons rechercher toutes les
hausses de dépenses nous allons lycée
des débats ce je vous ai dis nous car
nous avons déjà considérablement purger
ce qu'il y avait actuellement il ne
reste plus que un peu plus de cinq cent
mille euros de dépenses qui n'ont pas
été commandes et de factures que nous
n'avons pas encore pu passer dans la
comptabilité
donc ça veut dire qu'on a fait purger
déjà plus d'un million donc on va
continuer à purger
on va aller chercher par tous les moyens
de fonctionner c'est le cas du dr de la
dsp du musée je n'allais pas attendre
que des conséquences sur le service ont
rénové le musée mais de l'autre côté on
parle toujours des dépenses ne parle pas
des recettes les sites de saint pierre
et sites historiques par exemple depuis
30 ans ou 40 ans on a oublié de les
faire payer ne serait la seule à d'art
et d'histoire de france où les sites
historiques sont en accès gratuit
donc on va aller chercher les origines
et les financières pour cela comment oui
oui oui actuellement je n'ai pas
beaucoup de ressources humaines c'est là
aussi que je demande à l'état de me
comprendre les la comptabilité de la
mairie est en forte carence de compéter
de compétences là j'ai recruté un
financier qui a fait un excédent de
travail avec la chambre régionale des
comptes qui a clarifié la situation et
avec lui nous allons continuer à
travailler pour améliorer des comptes
petit à petit prix c'est rafa le
pierrotin l'api routine
vous savez au bout d'un moment dans son
quotidien il n'a pas envie d'entendre
que le maire a rencontré une situation
difficile parce que lui l'homme de la
rue la femme de la rue l'envi d'une
d'une ville qui rayonne tout simplement
et il n'a peut-être pas envie de
pleureuses à la mairie je ne suis pas un
pleureur et ils le savent parce que
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai pris sur moi
cette situation et je vous dis c'est
l'éclat parce que quand j'ai fait
l'audit en début de mon mandat c'était
peau et on nous a dit voilà c'est
l'audit que le maire voulait entendre et
que c'est pas vrai la chambre régionale
de faux comptes concis confirme cet
audit
si j'avais voulu pleurer et dire que je
n'avais pas d'argent savez ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire pour purger sa dalle
des si je voulais avoir purgé sa
aujourd'hui augmenter les impôts à peu
près deux ou trois fois plus à l'est ne
pas renouveler le contrat de 2,2 de
quasiment 30 30 personnes dans la mairie
et ensuite arrêté toutes les animations
de saint-pierre et tout ça non nous
sommes allés chercher la labellisation
de cap nau pour le médecin pierre
nous allons chercher les collaboration
public privé nous avons cherché partout
une façon de faire fonctionner la ville
sans qu'il y ait besoin d'eux
de fonds financiers de la ville donc je
ne suis pas en train de pleurer j'agis
pour gérer des finances simplement la
vérité que c'est rafa sait que la
campagne est déjà lancée comme un peu
partout dans toutes les communes de
martinique et que cette situation
avec ce rapport de la chambre régionale
des comptes c'est peut-être un argument
face à l'équipe de raphaël martin qui on
va le rappeler un dès le lendemain de sa
défaite de mars 2015 face à vous battait
déjà le pavé pire au teil à lui que 109
voix d'écart est ce que celle que sar
ccc ccc pour l'homme à pinailler sur
l'arithmétique est un peu plus de 109
bon allez 114 ou quelque chose comme ça
c'était l'expression de piloter mais oui
vous avez juste oublié que nous avons
aussi est-il lui un an après une
déclaration de d'annulation des
élections de saint piat point sécurité
du scrutin
donc je suis face à quelqu'un qui ne
sait faire qu'une chose c'est la
campagne la campagne elle m'intéresse
pas là je travaille j'ai beaucoup de
choses encore dans les tiroirs
cette année nous allons avoir des nous
avons assez d'hommes que vous travaillez
que c'est une façade
c'est une façon de faire campagne parce
que je veux un vrai bilan à la sortie
parce que je demande toujours le bilan
de nos prédécesseurs
voilà donc c'est ça qui fera la
différence les pilotait jugeront vous
êtes d'humeur au travers on veut bien le
croire à vous avez accueilli récemment
le président de la république le
président issu de la république en
marche fait partie du bureau politique
dans marche martinique tout comme vos
collègues du lourd est de 15 kg du stop
l'enfiler rate les rires oui riez vous
devant les pires août et en affichant
cette sympathie pour un parti
présidentiel plutôt en disgrâce au jour
ce n'est pas le problème de la problème
de saint pierre n'est pas le problème
du plaisir est ce qu'il est en mesure de
prendre votre carte est en marche
je n'ai pas de quatre marchés en marchés
te perds c'est un mouvement très ouvert
il ya des gens qui sont moi je sais que
il ya des grosses difficultés je pense
qu'il ya peut-être quelques petites
erreurs qui ont été faites sur le plan
de la communication et sur le plan de la
proche des choses je suis je comprends
le mouvement actuel d'aidé gilet jaune
je suis prêt maintenant à ouvrir à
participer à l'ouverture de cette parole
de la du peuple qui en a qui qui a des
choses à dire et qui vont certainement
très surprendre parce que c'est
difficile ce pays a besoin de réformes
évidemment fissiles quand même de dire
qu' on essaie partisans et membres dans
marche ça vous d'aujourd'hui non mais il
y a un travail qui a à faire pour la
france
maintenant on peut discuter de la façon
de le faire mais pas du fait que la
france est dans une situation
extrêmement difficile
c'est pas à vous que je vais la prendre
vous êtes au fait de l'actualité et qu'
il faut que la france se réforment le
problème actuellement népal celui de
macron ou pas macron parce que kim et
ratons à la place marine le pen en tout
cas le problème il est de celui de la
france est ce ça qui m'intéresse merci
qui sera favorite et ce matin avec nous
dans son clavier rappelle que vous êtes
le maire de la ville de saint pierre la
ville d'art et d'histoire bonne journée
merci